after a weekend of dramatic White House
emergency actions U.S President Joe
Biden on Monday announced that the
banking system is safe Biden made the
announcement following the collapse of
Silicon Valley and Signature Bank last
week two of the largest bank failures in
U.S history on Friday U.S authorities
shut down Silicon Valley Bank to protect
depositors doing the same on Sunday for
Signature Bank but Biden says even
though both are now under Federal
control unlike the 2008 financial crisis
taxpayers won't foot the bill no losses
will be borne by the taxpayers let me
repeat that no losses will be borne by
the taxpayers instead the money will
come from the fees that Banks pay into
the deposit Insurance Fund instead the
cost of covering the deposits will be
paid for out of an emergency fund set up
by a government agency known as the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation or
FDIC it's funded on a quarterly basis by
the Banks themselves additional bailouts
will also come from selling off Silicon
Valley Banks assets
the banks finding their own bailout not
the taxpayer is a key difference from
2008 when the troubled asset relief
program or tarp used taxpayer money to
purchase 700 billion in toxic assets
from the banks and unlike in 2008 those
who sought to make money through
Investments also won't be saved with
taxpayer funds investors in the banks
will not be protected
they knowingly took a risk and when the
risk didn't pay off investors lose their
money that's how capitalism works on
Monday anxious customers waited outside
New York's Signature Bank everyone
should be worried this is
The Fallout from the bank in crisis
isn't just an economic problem for
President Biden but also a political one
with still soaring inflation and an
economy in recovery the White House
knows the president can't afford any new
economic shocks Justice is set to
announce his 2024 presidential
re-election campaign
Kimberly helkin Al Jazeera the White
House